en janvier dernier l'ancien journaliste
et présentateur patrick poivre d'arvor
était accusé de viols et d'agressions
sexuelles par l'écrivaine florence
porcel l'ancien présentateur vedette a
visé par une enquête pour violence tout
est parti mais dany vecchio d'une
plainte de l'écrivaine florence porcel
depuis dans la presse et les médias les
langues se délient
si certains confirment que l'attitude de
ppda envers les femmes a toujours été
très déplacé clairement on voyait
arriver avec sa séduction voyais arriver
axé ses gros sabots comme ça à venir
vous draguer tout ça d'autres comme son
ex compagne claire chazal le défendez le
disculpe de toute violence quelle
qu'elle soit bien qu'étant séducteur il
n'était en rien ni dans la violence ni
dans la force jusque là silencieux ppda
décidé de prendre la parole mercredi
soir sur tmc pour s'expliquer sur les
faits s'il a réfuté toute accusation en
expliquant que c'était une époque
totalement différente de celle
d'aujourd'hui une phrase n'est cependant
pas passé inaperçu j'avais parfois des
petits bisous dans le cou parfois des
petits compliments aux ce comportement
aujourd'hui n'est plus acceptée par les
jeunes générations
suite à cette séquence beaucoup se sont
indignés trouvons ces propos totalement
déplacée puisque sur le coup je suis
désolé c'est pas du charbon fournit un
jeu c'est intrusif un crémant là c'est
vraiment très intrusif et qui semblerait
que lors de cette interview ppda est un
peu plus creusé sa tombe
et vous êtes vous choqué par la phrase
de ppda
alors bon
donc on lui donne un petit feu sur le
bateau parce que j'ai vu mon ami raquel
garrido qui a été excellente hier soir
aux côtés d'eric naulleau vraiment bravo
à vous pour votre émission il reçoit
d'ailleurs vous allez rester avec nos
six sur le sujet avec jean messia j'ai
cru que ça vous allez dire que la
prochaine fois c'est moi qui anime et on
en reparlera l'instant on à sabrina
michel qui était avec no mercy mercy
sabrina des merci beaucoup
alors vous êtes écrivain et vous faites
partie du cercle très proche de patrick
poivre d'arvor et à cette vidéo cette
phrase polémique de patrick en avant qui
a fait énormément parler on va la revoir
et vous allez nous dire ce que vous en
pensez ce que vous vous êtes choqués par
cette phrase ou pas et bien sûr on va
voir votre avis et vous allez nous dire
vous serrez que vous le connaissez
depuis des années et vous avez une très
très bonne relation
face à ça se passe très bien vous êtes
ami avec lui depuis combien de temps 17
à 17 ans ah oui c'est plus que moi avec
castaldi non quoi ça ça fait 17 ans que
l'annoncé pas bien répartie comportement
où il y avait parfois des petits bisous
dans le cou parfois des petits
compliment ou parfois du charme ou de la
séduction
ce comportement aujourd'hui n'est plus
acceptée par les jeunes générations
- j'ai peut-être draguer je pense que
j'ai jamais fait de drague lourde mais
il est possible que aujourd'hui des
femmes se sentent agressés ou en tout
cas ne ne vivent pas ça bien
alors qui est choqué par cette phrase
gilles verdez bien sûr bisous dans le
cou c'est très simple selon le code
pénal une agression sexuelle c'est toute
atteinte sexuelle commise avec violence
contrainte menace ou surprise bisous
dans le cou c'est une agression sexuelle
donc légitime est comme ça le bisou dans
le cou c'est une folie ppda il reconnaît
l'agression sexuelle de films mais cette
phrase en fait elle est horrible parce
que draguer c'est une chose mais quand
on dragons restent à distance à partir
du moment où on va on touche on fait des
bisous on rentre dans la dans la zone
d'intimité de la personne on viole sa
zones d'intimité
donc là en disant ça il se grille c'est
vraiment triste pour lui alors si vous
répondez hassan et de déchets jamais je
n'avais pas vu l'émission jardinerie
plein air force si on regarde très peu
cette émission
donc alors forcément après moi je suis
tellement impliqué émotionnellement dans
cette histoire que peut-être que je
manque d'objectivité forcément que pour
moi un homme qui va faire un bisou dans
le cou à une femme qui ne comprend pas
ça me choque sûr il en faut beaucoup
moins pour qu'elle réagisse et pour que
ça me rendent mal mais en fait votre
votre votre relation avec lui votre
amitié pour lui fait que vous vous dites
je le connais donc peut-être ses
intentions n'étaient pas celles que na
en gros sont tous ici c'est surtout le
contexte dans lequel s'était dit moi ce
que j'ai vu c'est yann barthès qui
demande à pépé diack
je vous pensais qu'à décote différente
séduction par rapport à votre génération
qui lui répond je chars mais je draguais
où je fais des bisous dans le cou
est-ce que j'adhère à ça non bien sûr
que non
le pour moi c'est déjà ce que moi
j'accepterai pas non plus mais j'ai
quand ça fait le jeu concert a fait
polémique jean j'ai cru que c'était
parce qu'il l'avait dit qu'il l'avait
fait à alain plaignante qui en fait
n'était pas à le contacter et je
voudrais dire un truc sur yann barthès
et lyn thériault que j'ai vue d'une
interview me voilà en replay et il ya
plein de gens qu'on critique et yann
barthès et je le dis moi franchement et
je trouve qu'il pose les bonnes
questions à ppda qui va poser des
questions qu'on leur pose ici on
n'aurait pas fait mieux
ici dans l'interview que ppda sais pas
ce que vous en pensez mais j'ai trouvé
voilà qui va poser quand même des
questions il avait été quand même voilà
il y avait posé des questions assez du
assez dure comme elle ne suis pas sûr
voilà que j'aurais fait mieux que ce que
j'ai vu pas mal de gens critiquer son
interview voilà je préfère dire je suis
pas sûr qu'on aurait fait mieux ici ou
que j'aurais fait mieux un jour dit il
la peint en moins sûre d'elle et de sa
zone de confort série là il n'a pas non
plus énormément sorti de sa zone de
confort mais à mon avis c'était
peut-être un il a été peut-être c'était
peut-être un deal aussi exactement on
est dans la soie munich à ce qui se
passe aussi avec des invités des invités
qui viennent et disent mais attention
vous ne parlez pas de si vous me parlez
pas de ça donc après on peut pas savoir
ce qui c'est moi c'est rigolo mais je
vous dis je suis pas sûr que j'aurais
fait mieux que lui dans l'interview
parce que je vois qu'il ya beaucoup de
gens qui l'ont critiqué sur sa je suis
pas tout à fait d'accord avec l'opinion
populaire mais moi je suis d'accord avec
l'argument de [ __ ] en ce sens où les
moeurs ont changé depuis vingt ou trente
ans ça c'est une certitude ensuite ppda
il est accusé de viol est-ce que des
petits bisous dans le cou
c'est un viol techniquement tu investis
aux accusations en disant il est des
petits bisous c'est un viol
oui si la réponse est oui ça veut dire
qu'il ya des viols chaque semaine dans
les boîtes de nuit et vous êtes vous
n'avez jamais vu un homme et une femme
ou un homme est un homme peu importe
dans une fable d'une phase de séduction
même entre des personnes consentantes
avec quelqu'un qui essaye d'en brasser
l'autre et ils auront tout cas si les
séances pas en position d aide joël que
nous en fallait lui mais non mais non il
dit les minimes et hi fi prohibe il met
en parallèle des petits mots ou des mots
gentils et à nous dans le coup donc ça
n'a pas de sens entre étrange évidemment
têtu et dîners quelqu'un ça se passe
bien tu es dans la séduction tu peux
l'embrasser mais c'est consentis
allaient finalement on doit être de nick
combien de fois on a vu des femmes
repoussent et des hommes qui sont un peu
lourds européens est ce que c'est une
année à l'honneur alors ils ont fait des
violences un bisou dans le cou et nalaga
se fait déjà mais non mais pas le propos
sabrina sabrina non tchéquie pour
patrick poivre d'avor ce que vous dites
c'est pas bon c'est pas votre père c'est
pas votre meilleur ami c'est patrick oui
exactement
en fait j'ai écrit une lettre il ya dix
sept ans que j'avais lu le livre qu'il
avait écrit pour sa fille moi
j'étoufferai d'anorexie et j'ai écrit
une lettre suite à la lecture de ce
livre là pas celui là donc un le livre
pour sa fille et il m'a répondu
il m'a proposé de venir à tf1 puis un
peu des similitudes avec la plaignante
c'est que je vous en avais on a le même
âge aussi écrit 06 21 23 ans je suis
j'étais à tf1 c'était en 2003 j'étais
dans les bureaux de patrick pendanx
peut-être cinq 5 ans une fois par année
et puis lui m'a toujours encouragé à
l'écriture jeu mu d'ambiguïté jamais
jamais dit ça mais dans glee lui et je
veux dire c'est un homme qui m'a amené à
hama guerre qui les a beaucoup aidés
mais énormément et alors je suis pas du
tout en train de faire le procès parce
que moi j'ai une belle soirée jeune
homme qui m'a respectée je sais que les
histoires sont différentes
bien sûr vous ne dites moi que c'est pas
la même chose pour auxerre il s'est
passé quelque chose pour florence et non
merci de votre expert exactement moi
depuis deux semaines je vis un enfer
parce que moi j'ai envie de défendre mon
histoire mais j'ai avec lui qu'elle
s'insère mon livre il a sorti en
septembre
donc c'est pas comme si je venais
maintenant pour s achever le livre il a
sorti avant 7 280 pages avec tout ce qui
m'a aidé et vous savez quand on souffre
d'anorexie
là est peut être toutes les addictions
la personnalité elle est bouffé et moi
m'a nommé relief féminin toute ma vie je
n'avais plus rien y avait plus de vie
intime plus rien et patrick
il m'a énormément aidé pour que je
redevienne une femme qui se respecte qui
ne tolère pas n'importe quoi donc quand
j'ai appris ça ya deux semaines moi je
me suis pris six trains dans la fisa pas
cela en plus vous êtes comment elle a
pris elle a regardé à prendre ou à
laisser
ouais c'est ça et en fait et j'ai teasé
sur le sujet comme patrick poivre
d'arvor et c'est comme ça que vous
l'avez appris oui ça fait afin
d'attendre à nous préparer avec elle
avec michael était surtout pris qu'il
était qu'il était mort en fait vous
n'avez pas nier les comptes vous avez
dit je vous ai dit après la pub comme ça
oui et je me suis dit non il était temps
que j'explique mal les choses non mais
voilà non mais en tout cas c'est bien
qu'on ait way votre avis les est votre
sentiment et votre histoire et patrick
parce que voilà pour elle c'est une
toute autre histoire que pour florence
pour vous au contraire
keith a été quelqu'un qui vous a
énormément aidé et qui vous a sorti
d'une maladie qui fait énormément de
dégât raquel la question pour vous est
ce qu'elle vous choque la phrase de
patrick poivre d'avor bien sûr mais
gilles verdez la l'a très bien expliqué
guillaume se fait l'avocat du diable en
faisant semblant que les bisous dans le
cou c'est pas un viol et que comme c'est
pas un viol du coup c'est pas une
agression mais gilles verdez a bien fait
le point de la situation sur le plan
juridique c'est bien une agression
sexuelle mais au delà de la
qualification juridique on est bien en
fait on met le doigt sur quelque chose
de plus profond le culturel en fait ce
qui parle de deux des générations ayant
qu il ya des générations ou c'est
acceptable et aujourd'hui ça ne l'est
plus et ce qui est frappant c'est que
cet homme là encore aujourd'hui en 2021
ne comprend pas en fait il a l'air de ne
pas comprendre que lorsqu'on est dans
une situation de pouvoir de magistère
professionnel moral artistique dans les
dents les parties n'importe où
là où vous avez en dessous de votre rang
des personnes qui est peut-être grâce à
vous
auront un emploi auront un rôle auront
la pauvre pour est préfacé le livre
comme c'est votre cas que sais-je
eh ben vous vous abstenez vous vous
abstenez quand bien même quand bien même
il y aurait une jeune femme qui est
prise ou vous mettez dans une illusion
de bonnes stratégies professionnelles
peut-être au donnerait l'impression de
consentir à quelque chose il faut
s'abstenir et moi j'ai envie de chacun
et madame jeu j'aimerais que vous lisiez
le livre de florence porcel et
j'aimerais que vous lisiez les pages où
elle raconte justement dans ce livre de
penderie ni elle raconte cette scène qui
a eu lieu dans le bureau de l'ue
personnage dont on comprend qu'il est
patrick poivre d'arvor parce qu'en fait
on comprend toute la complexité la
complexité de de passer à la casserole
quand on est une femme et de cette
espèce de d'invraisemblables négation
dont font preuve les femmes qui passent
à la casserole ou elles ne savent pas
vraiment précisément ce qui leur arrive
elles ne savent pas précisément elles
sont pas en capacité de dire ouï dire
non dans le livre de florence porcel
c'est bon ou pas ce qui m'a pris ma je
trouve absolument bouleversant c'est que
même elle alors il ya 39 ans d'école
vite parce qu'on a très jeune mais je
suis allé au très jeune c'est une
étudiante elle est face à un homme de
pouvoir qu'à 39 ans de plus qu'elle est
même elle va faire un peu semblant de
consentir et pas alors que elle est
vierge qu'il le sait qu'il a eu des
messages avec elle et qu'à la fin il lui
dit vous rendez compte j'ai fait de vous
une femme dont la la je pense qu'on peut
pas se permettre de dire ah bah non il
est sympa d'ailleurs dans le lieu
sabrina l'a raconté sur cette expérience
et c'est très gentil de votre part
d'être venu nous raconter votre
expérience parce que voilà c'est un
autre point de vue que celui de florence
et c'est important également de lavera
j'espère qu'au florence viendra nous
voir un jour dayan sur ce plateau